Airbnb by the way this is another thing
that I called Airbnb is dying Airbnb is
dying for a few reasons and I'm not even
gonna go into the fact that I'm banned
from Airbnb we all know why a lot of us
do you can watch the episode
but Airbnb exploded during the pandemic
people really wanted to kind of vacation
in other people's lives
the pandemic opened up every door of
possibility people were going maybe I
want to live in Houston
maybe I want to live
outside in Nashville and an Airbnb
allowed you
to basically manufacture the experience
of somebody who was living in that
locale
you would stay in their house you'd swim
in their pool
you would go to the coffee shop you'd
see what it would be like to live in
Charleston or Atlanta or Miami or Austin
or Phoenix Airbnb was huge hotels were
closed and the ones that were open
didn't have Services you couldn't go to
the gym couldn't get any room service
it made a lot of sense to be by yourself
with the other people that you were
quarantining with in an Airbnb and cook
your own food and sit out uh on the
porch or on the back deck
well the world has come roaring back and
that has not been good for Airbnb
airbnb's revenues are plummeting they're
down nearly 50 percent in cities like
Phoenix and Austin
the Airbnb collapse is pretty real
and now a lot of these um and and here's
what happened with Airbnb and I'm not
going to rehash what I went through with
Airbnb except to say this the Crux of
the problem that I had with those two
women
was that they expected me to clean up
the house
after I had paid a cleaning fee in
excess of four hundred dollars
I did later threaten to kill them that
wasn't
but the the Catalyst for the whole issue
and have them killed I'm not gonna kill
them have them kill put money behind it
and do it right but the the the issue
the Catalyst for it was why am I paying
a cleaning fee
in addition to that having to clean it
didn't make any sense it felt strange it
felt weird
so there was that whole big war and of
course Airbnb siding uh with them which
is fine now Airbnb is collapsing haha
but what what had happened is Airbnb
started as like this funky cool thing
and then the rules came
you can't be outside after 10 o'clock no
visitors
we're watching you on camera if we see
anyone that we don't you know there's
anybody's got they don't have a license
they they can't be here if they're not
checked in if they're not an official
guest
we don't want to see them airbnb's weird
and creepy we used to check into airbnbs
that we were almost certain a guy was
like they're several minutes before you
checked in it was really weird and we
also felt a few times that they had
entered the house when we weren't there
when we came back
Airbnb is a criminal organization
a lot of disgusting people are renting
their homes on Airbnb their their
voyeurs they're spying on you and
they're potentially dangerous this is
the reality this is no joke now Airbnb
has gotten away with a lot for a long
time with this and I think people have
to start understanding how vulnerable
you and your family are when you go to
an Airbnb a lot of the people who Airbnb
out their homes are sick
they're sick
they're rapists they're pedophiles
they're murderers and the reason that
they're trying to ensnare you in their
disgusting home is so that they can kill
you and your family and that's why the
the I'm not saying it's a bad business
model
I'm just saying that 50 of the ads of
top 50 because 50 of people want to live
they want to live they don't want their
children to be kidnapped by the owner of
the Airbnb
who's gonna make you clean the house up
before they put you in a box
in the basement
have you ever met anyone who airbnb'd
their house let's be very honest have
you ever met these they're no no no one
will admit it no one will tell you they
do it so whoever these sick freaks are
whoever these Disturbed I've only spoken
to a few people that have their houses
on Airbnb and they're all without
exception Disturbed
they're Disturbed
I don't trust them
remember that Airbnb story we did a
while ago where somebody checked it and
it was all like satanic imagery and all
kind of these are the types of people
that are on Airbnb get up one of these
people uh one of these Airbnb hosts and
we'll listen to them in their own words
because I always like to give the
opposing point of view time on my show
of course Airbnb did not do that for me
but that's okay what I have discovered
through my limited dealings with people
on Airbnb that are renting out their
homes is that there's something not
quite right with them
there's something not quite right
oh dear
here we are
here's what we've learned and what we've
earned after six months on Airbnb
and if you're new to the channel July of
2021 we bought this house
so what this is interesting because this
is again this is a pandemic thing
we're going to realize by the end of
this
that this is this Airbnb unlike Uber
unlike some of the Great
advancements and achievements
of our business community and our Tech
Community Airbnb is an aberration it is
Unholy it is satanic it is demonic
three and a half months and then
launched on Airbnb in November of 2021
and we documented that entire experience
and we have a weekly Vlog series about
what it's like to own an Airbnb in the
Joshua Tree area so if you're curious by
the way the two people were they were
lesbians the two people that I had
issues with an Airbnb uh were lesbians
and so it's not them
but this is what happened to Joshua Tree
a lot of people started uh coming up
with these airbnbs because everybody
wanted an escape
and Joshua tree for a certain type of
person is a great escape
and I would like to know what they
learned what did they learn what a what
is a couple like this learn when they do
Airbnb
because usually
the party line from all of these owners
is that nobody respects my house
I just opened my house and people showed
up and they started eating and living in
it
I just wanted to make a little money but
people started showing up [__] in my
toilet yeah you rented out your house
you pig
people showed up eating [__] in my house
they're all angry that people dared to
do the thing they paid to do which is
live in the [__] house
this first section's on deep cleaning
why it's necessary okay first thing they
learned yeah let's let's hear why that's
necessary
deep cleaning is a must we self-manage
our property so we come about once a
month and do a deep clean where we just
pull up all the rugs get under
everything and just really make sure
that the house is being maintained our
cleaners really let us know what's going
on in the house kind of surface level it
just allows you to look in places that
your cleaners don't normally do or and
it's your house so you know if
something's wrong something's out of
place something's going to be an issue
people are they're neat freaks but
they're they're clean freaks they're
sick there's something wrong with them I
love how they're like we self-manage and
then they're like our cleaners it's like
we do everything but clean that that's
what them Mexicans are for these white
devils
uh they're they're they're obsessed with
their hot they're sick do you see in
their eyes how sick they are they're
sick in the head these people and
they're obsessive about their [__]
[__]
and all they care about is like how
spotless it is keep going
so yeah here's more cleaning
that leads us to cleaners being the most
important piece of your puzzle when it
comes to your Airbnb I cannot stress
that enough we had some issues in the
beginning trying to find a great cleaner
out here in the high desert so you
definitely have to weed through the
weeds to get to the gems it's a work in
progress always because maybe something
is out of place or whatever and it's
always communication is key when it
comes to your cleaners and if you have a
management company don't even listen to
this because they're going to be dealing
with your cleaners but if you are
managing it yourself that's like my one
of my full-time jobs is managing this
house so I'm always Michael too always
in constant communication with our
cleaners and them letting us know what's
going on and just making sure because
I'm sorry
there's a spill in the sink there's a
spill in the sink
do something
constant communication with the cleaners
lucky cleaners huh
but these are the types of people
this thing with this group of people
there's a certain group of people who
they gave their lives meaning were by
buying and renovating a house
it's strange and then opening it up for
other people to live in and they're
perpetually unhappy because they can't
afford to live in their [__] house
because they think they're this get rich
quick scheme causes these people to
renovate this house make it really nice
and then do what they never wanted to do
which is open the doors to other people
and then they become angry at their
guests
they become enraged at their guests like
they've done something wrong and they
write all these passive aggressive rules
and they tell them it's basically like
hi thanks for checking in now [__] you
and let me tell you why I'll tell you
why look in their faces they're unhappy
that other people are coming into their
home
here's the section on reviewing bad
Airbnb guests this is oh boy your
situation right here
for the first few months after you've
launched your Airbnb you're really
relying on reviews and you're terrified
of getting bad reviews right but there's
a thing called bad guests and they'll
happen and you're going to need to speak
your truth when you have guests that
didn't follow the rules that is a huge
thing that we've learned we've had a
couple bad guests and we've given them
decent Stars
as far as the review and then within the
review we say like what's up what
happened
so that other hosts know maybe we don't
want to book them or like caution when
booking them because we know we rely on
when somebody requests to book our place
we look at their reviews and so we at
first we didn't realize how important
that was but now that we've had bad
guests we realize just how important
that is and just stepping your ego out
of it that's a big lesson removing your
ego and just being like hey these are
the things that you know didn't really
line up with our with our checkout
policy just do them in a nice way or
check out right because they want you
before you check out of an Airbnb they
want you to clean the entire house
you know they take every bottle of water
God forbid there's a bottle of water in
the refrigerator that's half drying
that's all got to get thrown out the
garbage has got to be out the entire
house has got to be cleaned even though
you paid a cleaning fee every towel's
got to be washed and fold it's like guys
what's the [__] point
that's why your the revenues are down 50
and people like her and him are going
belly up and I love that
pitch the tent
because this is what's happening these
people
are out they're being they're being
driven out of the market they're being
driven out of the market
um because they have a sick
and twisted obsession
okay with this weird curated experience
they're trying to give people that
required like when she's like you didn't
follow the rules you see you see your
face when she said that
is your face when she said that she's
these are power hungry Psychopaths that
own these things and when she said that
you didn't follow the rules what she was
basically saying is I get to boss other
adults around I get to give them bad
ratings I get to give them a report card
I get to give them a report card because
they didn't follow the rules am I [__]
boxing Joshua tree and you could you
could slip out who that you know they
slip out every now and then who they
really are it was very hard to find a
cleaner in the high desert you gotta
weed through a lot of weeds
it's very hard to find a slave in the
desert can't find any slaves in the
desert there's not enough good slaves in
the desert for me
all right let's finish up with them
nobody you don't need to piss anybody
off if you need a vent go to your
journal or your best friend not Airbnb
like it's Facebook you know what I'm
saying yeah
[Music]
so dogs are going to come into your
house whether you like it or not and
this is for our California and New York
friends we have gotten an abundance of
requests asking we'd love to book your
house but saw you didn't have a pet
pets we have an Esa animal if it's a
certified service animal absolutely no
problem that's fake yes a animal no
problem thank but there is some sort of
confusion and weird trickiness in the
way people use the esa animal California
we can't charge for pet fees for guest
who visits with an Esa and we are not
allowed to decline the presence of an
Esa and where it gets kind of tricky is
you're not allowed to ask for I actually
agree with them on this it's fake
because California's government is
stupid they allow people to scam You by
taking their dog to your house and
saying it's emotional support animal
which is fake and doesn't exist it
exists only for severe autism and blind
people
everyone else that's it and I mean
severe autism meaning like you're
non-verbal or it's like five words
if you are not severely Autistic or
blind you do not get to walk around with
a dog that you like to squeeze it's all
stupid but they really can't say that
all right anyway we're not gonna go on
and on with them they're no better or
and no worse than the other people that
are doing this but what I'm telling you
right now
is that I'm very very happy that this is
happening Airbnb because the American
public are getting smarter
they don't want to be subject to this
type of
insane treatment when you're spending
money
and to see these two
the passive aggressive anger
how you know excited they get
about rules and the checkout policy
it it takes all the fun away from owning
a house it takes all the fun away from
earning money it takes all the fun away
for
um from providing service to people and
that's why Airbnb is collapsing and the
only people that anyone who's staying in
Airbnb now is a [__] loser sorry
if you're an Airbnb now you're you're
you're a killer you're you're gonna kill
someone
because there's no person
I have not heard air am I wrong are you
guys hearing about people on airbnbs now
no hotels it's hotels or back [__]
airbnbs or no what are you doing walking
into somebody's house
what the [__] that about you freak
go to a hotel let's kill this thing
let's kill this thing once and for all
let's get rid of Airbnb let's make it
illegal let's see it for what it is a
place where violent white people do
horrible things can we get rid of it now